welcome back to another edition of faint
guru today or doing something real
simple I I found this on Twitter this is
a guru that approached Anthony Fantan oh
and I just want you guys to appreciate
the the arrogance combined with the
incoherence combined with the manic
state this person seems to be in so
without further ado I I give you Zack
the Zack attack the Zack heart dearest
Anthony I'm an influential mentor who
has consulted athletes CEOs celebrities
and more for over 30 years
while this email may seem like a pitch
of my services make no mistake this is a
benefaction for you I won't charge you
for this analysis but after you read
these words your head nodding yes will
be a certainty
hold on just to be clear I think he's
saying bye I won't charge you for this
analysis I think he means this email
like he's saying like I won't charge you
for this email that I'm sending you
right now because later it becomes clear
that he does want to charge you if the
defendant Oh we'll get to that I've
watched over a dozen of your YouTube
videos now remember guys this is free
advice okay just remember this is this
is a benefaction and this is free advice
I've watched over a dozen of your
YouTube videos and there is one
consistently in every clip there is
great weakness behind your eyes pause
and think this truth pause silence pause
think pause I'm available from May 20-22
April 22 he's available from May 20-22
April 2020 not from April 20 22 May 20
20 no from May 20 22 April 22 22 strim
mber that to meet with you in person
four times at a discounted rate of
$10,000 a session so so the analysis
that's free is definitely not the
sessions he wants to charge a lot of
money for the
sessions $10,000 to be exact my
mentoring will yield you this money back
and much more within a year's time I
leave you with a quote to consider illy
Corgan says in the 1998 song tonight
tonight if you held yourself up to the
light illuminate soon
and you know we never shut but you sure
you can't be right if you held yourself
up dude
[Music]
now the fame in your city by
ladies
[Music]
the
[Music]
leave me leave
[Music]